foreign contract with the Flyers was
tremendous in rookie camp and it's
been noticeable in the big Camp as well
yeah good start too good shift to start
the hockey game for that line Allison
moving in drops off right back down
and the Flyers have a one-nothing lead just
over two minutes in oh Allison and Brink follow
up a real strong shift by lucinski quickly as
Allison's able to drop the puck to Bobby Brink and
Frank who's on his backhand can keep the
goaltender Frozen Vanishing for the goaltender
yes to kind of Honor that backhand wondering if
he's going to shoot it or not and he's able to
freeze him and off his sticking wide to him all
he gets his back behind the net Kate Kate's in
the middle so he threw Brown back to Andre for
the shot clock out of the box now and moving
the other way are the Devils it's Thompson with a
puck Thompson with Lazar in a two on one head fake
in front they score it went off the Lazar and in
and the Devils just after killing off a power play
Dawson Mercer Excuse Me by Chris Tierney
and Thompson comes out of the box and that
leads to the odd man rush and real good
patience there by Thompson to outweight
the sliding I believe it was Eva laundry and able
to get it across and oh no wonder how to be better
in the Special Teams to have any Improvement that
week in between the last preseason game and game
number one it was a giveaway and a breakaway a
lot now two I know to Lazar and her makes the save
now it comes noodle Excel Excel is checked and
a chance in transition from the Devils he's here
on it drops it back Mercer Mercer dropping it
further back oh my gosh it comes the shot hard
to say rebound issue digging where is it Hartley's
back and the whistle stops play that's the case
the three saves that Carter has made have all
been great in this one is Ronnie and he's checked
behind the net he should typically [__] to
Meyer comes out in front Holt and he scores
Alexander olds 21 year old highly regarded by the
Devils they're waiting for this guy to take that
next step and be part of the mix for the big Club
it really has not been there this is a good four
check by he sure to kind of create this turnover
and see the pressure there by he sure Meyer able
to disrupt the play without her now you know kind
of a fortunate play for the Devils that that play
by Meyer goes off the skate of he sure right
to Holtz who's left all alone in front and uh
exactly I think for most hockey players guys
that I play with when you miss time you feel
like you're out of the loop and you can't help out
and you know you're supposed to be an important
part of the team Kelly Sutherland mohawkita
is working the game here tonight keep the arms
and he will hang right on to it real good feed
by Brendan Smith to find Paula streak into the
middle the Flyers defense got more concerned
about the players that were hanging out on
the walls and that left Hall wide open in
that forehand backhand move and he got in
the way of Andre now moves it but just the
line and misplace it and the Devils move up
Holt stays here this year back for Holt
to the backhand saved by her [Applause]
uh if it's a little off the speed of
this Devil's team in the transition
game that they can play with uh they
can create opportunities like this
because
it off couturier Waits fires [Applause] moves
on in this pass met for addered was broken up
played out in the center by Hamilton and
Meyer has a chance to get to this he will
turns it back to shot by Olson Hart clashes
across to knock that one down I'll back the
other way fires are on side Flyers turned
it over an opportunity for connecting the
shooting he did it Devils go the other way you
can see hearts he's moving to his right yet the
athleticism to kick out that left leg as he's
pushing across good job there by jinnin getting
back which kind of negated and then holds
swings wide takes a look all the way around
behind that out this side link cell continues
to look he finds good 38 for the shot blocked
go hard to get shots through now brown more like
cells right through the blue Mark stall in there
and it all starts with winning a draw
I think couturier you know he mentioned
in the interview wanting to
get his execution under him
I think these look pretty solid here tonight we
started the game in the line with considering
a connection now he's playing with Gardner
and brown and his Cam Atkinson has moved up
and racing the puck here for the shot as
Gardner in the save made but those are
young defenseman maybe cow foot can be a guy that
can kind of do what Ryan Graves did but Graves
oh Gates do crystal lighting who hits the crossbar
and goes out of play what a setup by Gates do a
good job in the offensive zone is because they're
willing to outnumber the opposition in the zone
and win pucks and cage with a no look behind
the back pass to risk the line I haven't shown
they can play a whole season and be of course in
the playoffs so that remains I'd say at least a
question mark for the note it is a question mark
and look I think in the regular season it's going
to be it's not going to be a problem I think it's
when they get to you know the final eight zinski
to Brown for a redirect that was knocked aside
neutral zone it's a good shift for the Devils
as they kept that line away from generating
much offensive and here comes geturian oh for
the shot and the shoulder saved by manishek off
of Bobby Brink Madre good read to step up and
intercept this play in the neutral zone and that
allowed the Flyers to go back the other way and
another great we'll see when Rocky Thompson
decides to get the goaltender to the bench
for the extra attacker as we take down towards
three minutes to play centering faster [Applause]
Brett Gardner this game is tied at two
probably the Flyers again strength in numbers
Brown able to fine Gardner in front who's left
all alone Gardner was going to go help out and
then he recognized that brown was okay
with the help of kumala so he got open
and brown was able to make the Nifty feed I
get it continual race up see if the Devils
can get one last bit here and they will
not Walker moving it to excel as a horn
sounds so 60 Minutes of preseason hockey
not enough for the second straight night
and I think you know the more you can
play them in the preseason it's good
for you too right get some practice
in it trying to get past each year
the shot had to check the save and he's able
to cover is to take Meyer out of the play and
then jump up into the play while Meyer was
out and advantagek fortunate here as he gets
kind of swimming out of the priest that that
puck ended up where email Andre was I mean if
Andre could have just stayed back a little bit
or if that puck was on his tape a little more
cleanly maybe we've been able to get it off
in a more time on the outside of course but
it stayed out and now Hamilton hasn't I just
got some signals crossed defensively there
now as Mercer escapes a check and moves on
Mercer racing up drops his back the shot and
they score it's Eric howler the overtime hero
for the Devils he beats heart and the devils
make it four wins in four games in the preseason
sending the Flyers to the overtime loss [Applause]